my therapist said to me once you know
rue the power you have in drag is
available to you
out of drag exqueeze me
for years i've said you're born naked
and the rest is drag
meaning everything you put on is in
essence
something that was built and once you're
able to see yourself from
outside of yourself that's when the
party begins
in this master class i'm going to teach
you about
self-love confidence joy lips
foundation wigs chiffon
everything it takes to unleash the magic
that makes you
you what you're going to see is raven
show you
step by step what it takes to get into
real
glamazon drag
drag doesn't change who you are it
actually reveals
who you are my childhood was very
tumultuous
and traumatic my parents were always
at war so my thinking was
this is all too much for me uh just wake
me when it's done
until i realize you know i want to be
present for my life
and it forced me to understand my own
value
everything starts with know thyself know
what works with you
you have to be present enough to know
what feels right
in drag i feel so powerful
it is your life's work to shine there
is strength and power in you but it's
up to you to realize it you were not
born to fit in you were born to stand
out i'm rupaul and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
you